i think he he didn't want to make any
statement right
no but i think he knows where the wind
is blowing here and it's not going to
blow him out of las vegas based on this
year
he's just got to be careful the checks
that he writes now
because what he's thinking is now we got
to prove that we can make the playoffs
not that we can win in a much higher
level now's the time to qualify for the
playoffs
right this ascension this grad if you
want to be optimistic
if you want to say glass half full or
glass 25
full or whatever it may be they're
building
but they still three years of gruden
no playoffs no playoffs no playoffs
getting close this year isn't going to
be good enough they got to get to the
playoffs this year and that's where
that's where he self-edited himself
chris
and and revised what he was thinking
into something that would not
be tantamount to writing the check we
got to get to the playoffs this year
yeah
the the pressure's there the
expectations are there now i mean
there's no avoiding that
you know you said it right it's your
four i mean hey
from who but who who where's the
expectation and the pressure from well
is it from mark davis or is it from
someone else no
it's really mark davis is the only one
who matters no you're right he's the
only one that matters but
but mark davis is also not like clueless
here too in the fact that
he can feel and if he's got any sense of
like society
that the raider fan base is antsy i mean
all you got to do is go on social media
just look at
raider stuff and you know it's all over
the place he does that though
well i don't i think somebody would keep
him aware
and he's maybe watches the news and has
people like aware of them of what the
talk and chatter is around his
organization so yeah i mean you're right
there's not like big time pressures from
mark davis but
if it continues this year into you know
a losing season or a year that doesn't
get to the playoffs
he's gonna hear the chatter of like oh
ten years hundred million dollars four
years he was still not in the playoffs
four years in the team still hasn't got
better eddie all of that
then that's gonna start to put the
pressure i don't think it's this year no
i don't think it's this year either
it's gonna but this year is going to
start it to where it gets real for next
year
that's that's i guess what i'm saying
yeah
think about it though they had that
brand new stadium and not a single fan
was in it last year
this year is going to be party time in
las vegas yeah
this year is going to be fill the
stadium and yeah there's going to be
fans of other teams there are people
going to be flying into las vegas to see
whoever the visiting team may be in a
given week but people are going to be
coming from california to see the
raiders as well
they're going to sell that place out
it's going to be a good time it's going
to be
a lot more revenue for a team that needs
the revenue
i don't think mark davis is going to be
all that caught up in playoffs this year
i
look i've said this before as well so
it's not going to get me in trouble i
assume to say it again
mark davis and john gruden are george
costanza
and tony the the hunky boyfriend of
elaine where george was smitten
with tony mark davis was is
and i presume will continue to be
smitten with john gruden
they're buddies is he going to fire his
buddy is he going to tell his buddy to
step off
tony doesn't get told to step off tony
tells other people to step
off and until that dynamic changes until
someone
intersects himself or herself between
tony and george aka mark and john
john gruden's going nowhere this i i
mean i
i hear you you're saying a lot of things
i agree with i get it
you know but but to me this is the last
free pass here
this is the last free pass here i do
think if we go into year five
and it's been four years previous to
that of we haven't done
playoffs or anything like that then mark
davis
is going to at least his mind is going
to start to think about that a little
bit
you know and and yeah you know i
understand john gruden he's
polarizing people love him hate him
whatever he's certainly like the face of
the franchise of the raiders and
everything like that
but it is vegas listen vegas the last
time i checked people still love to go
there
get drunk spend money do everything and
go crazy and party
they'll fill that stadium up no matter
who's the head coach i don't i don't
have any doubts about that
but getting back to the football team
itself
where it's weird right at least to me
is it's year four and
i i don't know it's just like it was a
little bit of a i don't want to say a
rebuild
but there was a a refurbishing of the
team here this off season to where we
kind of were like hey they're going in
this direction okay they got to do this
and all that
and it's like wait they're getting rid
of the o-line and they still got work on
the defense
and the the roster itself i just don't
think is still where gruden would want
it to be at least
from my standpoint sitting here looking
from the outside looking in
and we're going to hear a little more
from john groom but i i can't move past
the tony and george dynamic without
sharing with you chris and everyone else
my absolute favorite line from that
episode
when george explains his fascination
with tony
says george he's the first cool guy i've
ever been friends with in my whole life
you know it's a different world when
you're with a cool guy
he's not afraid of anybody you should
hear the way he talks to waitresses
he gets free pie that's that's great
so anyway um all right let's hear from
john gruden about the changes they made
to the roster the big changes on the
offensive line and elsewhere as they try
to get better
more from tony aka john gruden
well i'll have to see when we get to
camp
obviously we like it on paper we think
uh we've made some
some changes that are you know in some
people's eyes uh
questionable but we're younger i think
we're faster
i think we do have more depth and
it's hard to update that that question
right now without seeing everything
in pads at full speed
yeah hey look you know they're they're
trying they're trying to get better
defensively they are trying to make the
offensive line better they're trying to
make the receiving core better there's
only so much you can do in any one off
season and
i think look i this is another one i've
said before so
um why stop now this is the mike mayok
is on notice here this is not the john
gruden is on notice here
okay if they don't get to the playoffs
this year i think mayox out
not that they're going to find anyone
better than mayok to come in because
it's not the easiest job in the world to
fill
sure but i think this is the this is the
main last year was the paul gunther out
yeah this year is mike mayok out i think
last year was almost mike mayhawk out
and next year i don't know that next
year is john gruden out if it doesn't
work
but he's inching closer to out
uh if it doesn't if it doesn't turn
around this year or next year uh um i
mean
i'm with you there i can't disagree with
that statement i mean we just talked
about you know the roster where it is
there's been some swing and misses you
know yeah that'd be the easy guy to
blame there i
listen i still think it's weird that
gruden wasn't in the room with the first
pick of the draft with alex leatherwood
he wasn't there
i don't know that's just weird to me i i
did you sensed something though didn't
you i don't want you to talk about
anything that you're not
talking about because we've communicated
about this right what dynamics
since there may have been some there's a
little riff right that was kind of the
rumors i was hearing around the nfl
there's a little riff about the pick or
some
disagreement there in the in the first
round so uh
again i've heard that from people that
you know i really trust but i did find
that odd
there's no doubt about it we like you
mentioned we've had some swinging misses
here in
in the draft and i'm i'm i'm
i could certainly see that being the
case things don't go well
team doesn't perform all the way the way
it should or gruden's expectations that
mike
mayok becomes a scapegoat uh to a degree
fairly or unfairly uh but there's just a
lot unfairly
yeah greatness running that's just
running the show i get it
i know i know i don't know what their
you know
power ratio is or how much gruden you
know how much leash she gives them or
trusts him
i don't know i know you're right it's
gruden's show so ultimately it all does
come back to him
but yeah there's a lot of question marks
offensive line
see where that goes you know defensive
line yeah you got yannick and gawkway
that's good but i mean the
interior part of the defensive line is
still a question you got some young
talent in the secondary
but it's like abrams is all over the
place trey von bull in the corner
he's been kind of all over the place you
know they drafted a safety in the second
round this year
the receivers trayvon mary great from
tcu who to me is
even a little you know i thought that
that's a dicey pick
and then the receivers and everything
like that from the from the year before
haven't quite been what we expected so
there's a lot of like unproven
commodities and young talent that just
haven't flourished yet
let alone now they're putting together a
different offensive line of guys that
they like obviously
but like gruden said they got to get out
there and see them in pads before they
could figure out who's going to be where
and
what the starting five is going to be on
that offensive line
assuming as i think you will that john
gruden is in charge
right that you know the nine years he
spent kind of hovering over the league
he may come back is he going to come
back when's he going to come back he
finally comes back he swoops in with the
10-year 100 million dollar contract with
the raiders
de facto in charge of everything three
years in
give him a grade a fair grade not not
great inflation
but but a real grade of what he's done
so far
i'm gonna i i think fair i'm gonna say b
minus
b minus is probably about i would you
know b minus c plus is about where i was
c plus c plus thinking the grade that
ralphie got on his
theme about uh what he wants for
christmas yeah i was thinking c
plus yeah well you know he's he's wired
he's wired his quarterback
and got derek carr where he want him to
be there are some positives certainly on
the offensive side they became a force a
little bit on the offensive side of the
ball to a degree
but you know as we saw their defense
couldn't stop anything
and that to me will be also a huge thing
to watch you know the fact that they got
gus bradley
you know back back you know gruden's got
him back because they were together in
tampa and when i was there
gus bradley was there i do think that's
going to be you know
a positive for the defense as well he's
one of the better defensive minds in
football
nobody can coach the seattle scheme
better than gus bradley he invented it
so that's where you know i have some
hope for
one they know what they're doing on the
offensive line and what they did with
letting certain guys go and knowing what
they got come up in the ranks
and that that gus bradley will get some
of these young guys that we talk about
that have been all over the place
finally getting them to look the way
they should look or the way they want
them to look
but but that's great why not put the
seattle scheme in place when you get
hired though gruden was
all fired up about paul gunther because
he was bringing that mike zimmer defense
so you know i it always amuses me
when you know something doesn't work
the person directly responsible for the
thing that doesn't work
gets poop canned i almost said the other
word
but the one who decided that's what we
were going to do it's all well and good
and
you know we rattled off the numbers of
john gruden's record since winning the
super bowl his first year with the tampa
bay buccaneers and
and and i i i know i got them all hot
and bothered according to
the things you've heard when i pointed
out a very fair comment
anyone else the last three years with
the raiders
would be on the hot seat anyone else
would have potentially been fired after
the 2020 season
three chances to get to the playoffs and
you don't get there
and you're not showing significant
improvement and you're in charge
plenty of other owners would have turned
the page and it's up to mark davis
at the end of the day but man it really
it's it's great work if you can find it
in a competitive field like that
zero-sum game winners and losers 25
turnover every year if you can get one
of the jobs where the owner is going to
tolerate
failure to miss playoff over and over
and over again
that's a pretty damn good gig to have
yeah well i i know but you know
he has a history here with the franchise
of of success
you can say what you want yeah tampa
wasn't all great but he still did win a
super bowl went to playoff appearances
and there's a personal relationship with
the owner there are and
i mean listen i think that when he took
over the team
yeah it was a it was the understanding
he had with mark davis it was going to
be a total rebuild
he didn't like the current state of the
roster he wanted to get it to where he
why
they had just been i know you've been 12
and
four no yeah a few years before that i
understand but he felt like that one
year before that well they weren't 12
and four the year before he got there
no 26 12 and four two years they were 12
and four in 2016 right
they were 12 and four in 2016. obviously
they weren't going to fire jack del rio
and secretly hire john gruden into 12
and four seasons yes it was the sixth
ten the next year and then the next year
right they
they they he decided he was finally
going to bring john gruden hey listen i
don't know
jack del rio yeah i don't know if he
deserved to get fired but either way
gruden took over and he
he must have shared his vision with with
with mark davis let alone listen i i do
think that the raiders had cash issues
too come on that's no secret
and the fact that hey he came there
thinking he's probably gonna have khalil
mack on defense and some of these other
guys that
they couldn't afford to keep because
they couldn't pay them so that also has
to be taken into account i think
at least give a little credit to gruden
but he obviously wanted to do it one way
he had a vision he's told mark davis i
have to do it this way because i want to
play this way on offense and defense
they're getting better but yes we
haven't seen the results as
quickly as we'd like or what's really
kind of commonplace for this day and age
in the nfl
it's usually quicker than three years
and that's where we're questioning it
well again yeah we can talk about it all
we want
all that matters all that matters is
whether to what extent george decides
he's had enough of tony they're going to
go to the playoffs this year what is
your
what's your gut what's what's meatballs
don't pasta say
do i think they're going to yeah i think
they have to no well no
going to because i think we too early
yeah too early too early to tell
cause you got three good teams in the
division i think the broncos are going
to be better
you get the chargers who are on the rise
if they stay healthy and you got the
chiefs i would at this point say they're
not
going right but but there's still a lot
to be decided
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports